okay so I've been talking about how
American Indians almost had their own
state but right before Oklahoma was
about to swallow all of this tribal land
five of these tribes fought back they
fought back with the weapon that the US
government had used to take all of their
land paperwork they all met together in
a constitutional convention they wrote a
constitution they drew borders they
created counties they created everything
they needed to have their own State and
then they marched it all the way to
Washington DC they delivered it to
Congress and Congress didn't even look
at it the Republican president at the
time Teddy Roosevelt didn't want two
separate states he didn't want like an
Oklahoma and one for native people that
would mean more representation for
Democrats also the white folks didn't
like the idea of brown people having
their own state so they just killed the
proposal of this state that would have
been called Sequoia but there's hope to
this story because the Sequoia
Constitution didn't go to waste the
state of Oklahoma lifted the entire
thing to make their constitution